este sujeto está arrastrando un carrito
del mercado y está escuchando una
conversación unos pasos más adelante hay
una chica con un celular esta chica está
teniendo la siguiente conversación si
amiga te lo dije pero cuénteme pues como
así hay boda no claro que no
dígame ya no digamos aquí se pone típico
cierto pero no va a decir la palabra
para que no tengan que editar no es en
serio te lo dije [ __ ] claro yo sabía
que te va a encantar el semen de mi
novio
el sujeto a que está arrastrando el
carro
tiene que detenerse
debe tomar una decisión las decisiones
me voy para otro corredor o me quedo en
este corredor escuchando el resto de la
historia
todos somos el sujeto nos quedamos
detrás porque queremos saber por qué a
la amiga de la chica le gustó el semen
de su novio
sí
pero yo tengo en el semen del es súper
bueno y no me alegra mucho si el mes
pasado le salieron unas vacas holstein
super bonitas
vacas holstein super bonitas
entienden el problema
cuando a mí me invitaron a hablar en una
charla de lo primero que dije es y por
qué yo aprobé porque es que es bacano
que hablemos de la comunicación y cuáles
son los cambios de los paradigmas en la
comunicación y usted nos ha contado unas
cosas que son como saberes
lo primero que yo trato de decirle a los
estudiantes es mire no vaya a confundir
eso de lo ágil lo fresco lo dinámico y
lo atractivo con lo simple lo emotivo y
lo creíble
obviamente a mí me invitan a dar esta
charla y yo tengo un problema
siempre entró en pánico y llevo diez
años hablándole a la gente y tengo que
empezar a buscar digamos algunos
esquemas que permitan que yo pueda
sobrepasar esa barrera uno el más
clásico que tengo es que me quitó las
gafas y no los veo entonces es genial
que suma el de homero sí mismo
hoy si los tengo que ver porque tengo
que esperar la reacción de ustedes para
poder ir haciendo el paso de las
diapositivas y de antemano tengo que
pedirles paciencia el horizonte de
expectativas de esta charla breve es la
paciencia porque la tecnología siempre
huele mmm es mi miedo es o sea algo va a
suceder no sabemos qué pero están
pendientes
ahora el asunto es que me dieron cambios
comunicación entonces yo empiezo a hacer
una tarea y cuando uno le invitan a uno
de estos espacios yo trato de hacer una
metáfora para mí es como cuando te
invitan a un paseo en una finca yo yo
pregunto si es clima facebook si es
clima caliente si hay que llevar
pantaloneta si hay que hacer una vaca
para el asado y ese tipo de cosas es
decir que le pongan a uno el paraguas y
que te digan las dimensiones y las
perspectivas del asunto son estas y me
dieron cambio
y entre más pánico
le voy a decir por qué porque yo soy uno
de esos profesores que a pesar de estar
vinculado a una escuela de un
departamento que busca de alguna forma
encontrar como estos dispositivos y
estos mecanismos de la comunicación
están contribuyendo al cambio cree
ciegamente que nada ha cambiado que
realmente lo que está evolucionando y
transformándose tiene que ver con otras
cosas que no son necesariamente los
esquemas de la comunicación
y mucho menos el discurso young y la
invitación de ted y sorpresa en la
invitación de ted me dicen cómo hacer un
discurso y yo me quedé pensando a esto
es una charla que invita a propiciar un
encuentro con el cambio pero básicamente
me están enviando un manual que escribió
un señor que se llama con jacques antes
de que naciera jesucristo
estoy yo me puse a pensar yo un poco
como el vídeo el vídeo anterior a las
charlas
yo tenía que dar vueltas vueltas algunos
se habrán tropezado con un cuaderno que
tiene un gato dorado escribí cosas pero
obviamente yo soy youtuber o sea yo me
meto a ver clases de guitarra y
entonaciones y ese tipo de cosas
yo me disperso fácilmente
y básicamente era por la pregunta o sea
como les cuento a las personas que
realmente en lo que nos tenemos que
fijar es en una cosa que utilizamos todo
el tiempo y que la dejamos pasar por
alto
todos los discursos narrativos
expositivos demostrativos y descriptivos
tiene que ver con cuatro con cuatro
agentes fundamentales el primero de
ellos es el entorno donde se cuenta la
cosa pero después van los tres
ingredientes fundamentales de esa masa
la acción el personaje y la premisa
gramática todos volvamos a la historia
hay un personaje que se presenta cierto
está con el cargo del supermercado y de
repente escucha una conversación eso es
lo que se llama la captación benevolente
el momento en el que la otra persona
empieza a decir algo que sugiere en el
otro una imagen cuando yo dije yo sabía
que te iba a gustar el semen de mi novio
ustedes pensaron en el semen del novio
de esa niña
del novio
no pensaron en la inseminación del
ganado sino que pensaron en el semen
entonces ahí hay un signo particular y
comienza una peripecia comienza un nudo
debo hacer una aclaración soy profesor
de narrativa como soy profesor de
narrativa entonces así como dijo el
profesor anterior me tengo que
especializar un poco en un asunto y es
cuáles son las estructuras del discurso
ahí hay una peripecia ahí hay un medio y
el personaje que está en la acción tiene
que buscar la manera de resolver lo que
le acaban de plantear es decir tiene que
desarrollar
en sí mismo y dentro de eso que llamamos
la diégesis del relato la forma de
participar en ella es decir la meta o
premisa que tiene ese personaje es saber
el final de la historia
cuando nosotros narramos presentamos un
personaje determinamos cómo es la
evolución de ese personaje
tenemos un desenlace todo funciona de
esa manera cuando yo leí la carta de
invitación de tedio dije yo no puedo
hablar de cambio pero si les puedo
mostrar pistas de tal vez porque es que
no nos hemos dado cuenta que como muchos
de mis alumnos y a veces como muchos de
los profesionales que han estado a cargo
mío en diferentes instancias
nos hemos especializado en hacer de lo
simple complejo hemos pasado de lo
complejo
a simplificar las cosas y hemos vuelto a
volver complejo lo simple no es como
venga que vueltas estamos dando frente a
esto
fíjense en esta frase esta es una frase
muy particular que determina el punto
que quiero dejarles instalado
elegancia pureza y medida que eran los
principios de nuestro arte se han ido
rindiendo gradualmente al nuevo estilo
frívolo y afectado que estos tiempos de
talento superficial han optado
había gusta hablar del público
desprevenido si una desprevenidamente
lee esto y uno entiende que ahí dice
abajo de corelli music al magazine el
review no dice hace una crítica musical
a un género en particular como el
reggaeton sé que estás claro la gente
hoy en día
entonces
martín es obvio yo tengo 45 me
preguntaba si les gusta el reggaeton no
básicamente el argumento lógico y
correspondientes no soy joven
yo pertenezco a otra generación en
generación en la que creció con el gel
el grunge cierto después otro poco más
el el pop y el rap y después el hip hop
power metal y ya no trabajaba ya no y
esas cosas porque el pp lo miraba raro
sino iba en el carro y de pronto ponía
megadeth entonces eso era extraño pero
me tocó
si estuviese claro es que la verdad todo
ha cambiado demasiado
resulta que eso es un texto de 1824
es como water es en serio si resulta que
esta era la reseña
es para allá se los dije
esta era la reseña de un crítico inglés
sobre la novena sinfonía de beethoven
si en tres años donde lo dice vuelvo al
punto que es lo que ha cambiado la bien
en que en 1824 se hizo una cosa que
puesto en circulación dentro de una
sofisticación del lenguaje podría ser
parecido pero es exactamente lo mismo a
dónde voy yo
nosotros lo que hicimos
fue perdernos del paisaje
nosotros nos hemos alejado de una cosa
que para mí es maravillosa que la guerra
descubierto por fortuna en los últimos
años que se llama el alma de las cosas
así ahora bien si ustedes ven esta
fotografía y han entendido la premisa
que tengo porque ya más o menos se
encontraron que el discurso de donar
rápido los positivos lo demostrativo y
lo descriptivo siempre funciona en los
mismos términos aristotélicos si ven
esta imagen ya saben que no es de
instagram cierto ya saben que a pesar de
la escala de crisis y los valores
cromáticos la profundidad del encuadre
la composición todas esas cosas que ya
le facilita a uno una aplicación ésta
puede ser una una una fotografía ante
cierto pues bien si lo es es una
fotografía de 1942 es una fotografía de
ansel adams cuando avance la dan se le
contrata para hacer un recorrido
por el paisaje de los eeuu estábamos en
plena segunda guerra mundial y este
hombre completamente aislado aislado de
lo que estaba sucediendo en un contexto
global se dedicó a eso a retratar el
alma de la naturaleza el alma de las
cosas y cuando nosotros decimos del alma
de las cosas muchas de eso puede sonar
como esotérico hasta abrazar árboles
estás vegano no a mí tengo el alma de
las cosas es que de verdad nosotros nos
aceleramos sin remedio
seguramente algunos de ustedes tienen
una cosa que llama drive
ven y mandan el drive que es el drive el
braille es uno de esos mecanismos muy
simpáticos de la contemporaneidad para
las personas que vivimos en un universo
corporativo por qué por qué es ese tipo
de asuntos que por ejemplo a mí me tilde
a tendrá ya de por sí sin tácticamente
es una palabra nueva pero lo usamos todo
el tiempo resulta que no falta una
persona en el grupo que manda un tipo de
documento que no se puede editar en
línea
entonces tú tienes que descargar el
documento editar el documento en el otro
software ese que es súper riguroso bueno
potente que llama word y después de
hacer todos los cambios lo tenéis que
volver a asumir y ahí es donde uno dice
qué es lo que a cambio de que lo que no
es lo que nos ha facilitado la vida muy
poco realmente
una segunda historia muy breve
vengo del mundo de la televisión
para decir los cambios de lo análogo a
lo digital cuando éste padecía es que el
primer trabajo que yo tuve fue cargando
una cafetera
para muchos de ustedes casetera es un
asunto vintage cierto hay gente en el
público y habrá algunos nuevos hipster
tardíos pero casetera es esa cosa pesada
donde uno pone un casete de vídeo es
decir un cassette con una emulsión de
pvc electromagnética que permitía que se
grabarán cosas y se reprodujeran
inmediatamente el primer cambio
significativo de dispositivos que hubo
en la comunicación ocurrió en 1967 con
el vídeo y en adelante todo se vuelve un
problema todo se volvió más complejo
la gente dice es más difícil hacer cine
no lo que es más difícil es tratar de
decirle a una persona cuento primero la
historia cuente primero la historia
organice primero las ideas recuerden que
a mí me mandaron una carta con un mapa
de qué era lo que debería decir aquí lo
que yo les debo de decir aquí es hagan
la tarea más simple
estudian cuáles son las estructuras
discursivas visitan de vez en cuando
aristóteles vayan y verán que dijo hegel
de alguna manera siente curiosidad por
schopenhauer si quiere ir un poco más
allá pues lea a thomas alva leo y vea
cómo de alguna forma ese tipo de
estructuras argumentativas funcionan en
la vida porque es lo mejor que uno puede
hacer este tipo de charlas permite algo
que a mi juicio es fascinante
encontrarnos con la palabra encontrarse
con la palabra es una cosa que todos
estamos olvidando y el primer
dispositivo tecnológico que nosotros
tuvimos que fue el fuego permitía que
alrededor de él pudiéramos conversar
nosotros dejamos de conversar pero lo
más particular es que hemos
espectacularizado en la belleza como
decía el profesor anteriormente y
entonces claro este tipo de charlas nos
tienen que dejar inquietos bien que en
600 porque es que el asunto no tienen
nada que ver con la tecnología con que
yo aquí después vaya a quedar grabado y
eso puede hacer
cientos debe ser reproducido tiene que
ver con que voy a dejarles yo a usted
acá
allá
cuando estaba preparando la charla
no es que tengamos una pregunta es que
tengo 5 minutos
estaba leyendo nuevamente los bárbaros
de alessandro baricco uno tiene que
encontrar esos referentes conceptuales
que permitan que la idea de cómo las
cosas no necesariamente han cambiado
sino que nosotros las hemos hecho
complejas las utilice para estas
fotografías
nuevamente el asunto de que cambie y que
no cambia cuando no esa fotografía uno
tiene que ver el detalle uno no tiene
que ver la situación
uno tiene que ver cómo se está narrando
cuando uno en esta fotografía uno
inmediatamente ganar el tiempo porque
será mi intención cuando yo vi esta
imagen yo dije yo tengo que tomar esta
imagen cuando yo fui en ese año este es
el año 2012 son en 1942 cuando yo vi esa
imagen y yo vi a estos judíos en coney
island vestidos de esa forma yo dije yo
tengo que hacer este retrato pero mejor
aún en serio lo tengo que hacer en
blanco y negro porque porque yo quiero
engañar a la gente
eso es una sutileza mínima que pocas
veces entendemos cuando vamos a
estructurar un discurso nuevamente
avinieron habla de los paradigmas de la
comunicación cómo ha cambiado la
comunicación sorpresa no ha cambiado
mucho las estructuras discursivas
persiguen los mismos momentos no se les
olvide de manera narrativa es positiva
demostrativa descriptiva saben a cambiar
y que yo en mis viajes básicamente a
retratar eso como uno tiene pero como
uno puede leer una historia en cada una
de esas cosas
a cualquier precio estaba en londres de
alguna manera va a entender que esto
significa que es londres una persona que
puede tener tres trabajos el agite que
hay en la estación la señora que es
nativa de londres pero es al inmigrante
que se la está jugando y que se está
dejando el pellejo en cada uno de los
trabajos
si se da nueva york entonces se va a
encontrar con esa persona que también
tiene que contar esas historias pero
sobre todo de dónde viene en esa línea
en particular del metro así me encanta
tomar fotos del metro el chicago es
igual uno tiene que aprender a valorar
ese tipo de cosas y es decir ese tipo de
circunstancias
yo soy de este tipo de fotógrafo turista
vulgar que pide permiso porque si me
parece un poquito rudo y le tomando
fotos a las personas así como así pero
yo les pido permiso
pero esto es lo que me ha permitido a mí
en los últimos años de verdad
tratar de encontrar que nosotros
debemos detenernos un poquito debemos
pensar en la esencia de las cosas
al principio cuando estaba organizando
esta charla y ya para finalizar tenía
una idea iba a venir con una hoja de
periódico y le iba a pedir a ustedes que
hicieran un barco de papel o un avión o
un sombrero y se lo pusieran en la
cabeza porque eso de alguna manera es lo
que sintetiza lo que yo quiero que
ustedes piensen nosotros y en particular
en la comunicación nos hemos convertido
en unos expertos en hacer de lo simple
un asunto complejo muchas gracias